when it comes to Gotham City villains
you are one of the best Harley Quinn you
have such a fascinating story and are
one of the most complex characters in
Gotham The Joker might have been the
reason you turn to a life of crime but
your character has developed into
something way better than your
relationship with that madman
unfortunately the Joker tends to
overshadow your epic storyline both the
Joker and Harley Quinn are fan favorites
in the DC Universe these two crazed
villains don't have the healthiest
relationship and many people think
Harley is defined by the Joker but we're
here to tell you that Harley is way more
interesting than the Joker even if you
get to all the spotlight origins story
until the 2019 film the Joker we didn't
have a bunch of information about the
Joker's origin story through most of the
animated series in comics of the 1990s
his origin story is lacking he's just a
complex guy who's obsessed with Batman
but from the moment Harley Quinn is
introduced it's clear who has the more
interesting backstory Harley was first
introduced in Batman the Animated Series
Holly Quinzel rework it a bit and you
get Harley Quinn like the clown
character Harlequin she didn't appear in
the comic books until later
Harleen Quinzel had a criminal for a
father she became fascinated with what
makes criminals tick so she became a
psychiatrist
she works at Arkham Asylum and gets to
know the Joker she is fascinated by him
and falls in love with him he
manipulates her into helping him escape
it's interesting because she was trained
in how to identify manipulation but she
quickly falls prey to the Joker's lies
and promises then she makes the clear
decision to disregard her medical os--
to become a criminal it's such an
unlikely story and different from most
mad fighting skills okay we aren't
denying that the Joker is pretty handy
in a fight but let's be honest his
fighting skills are pretty basic she
relies on firearms and explosives a lot
of the time it's pretty common for
villains to use those methods so it's
not that exciting he isn't the best at
hand-to-hand combat Harley Quinn on the
other hand has some amazing me lay
skills and it is a lot to do with her
background she was trained as a gymnast
and Acrobat according to Batman the
Animated Series she was an Olympic level
gymnast this makes her great in a fight
and fun to watch No
wondered the Joker needed her as a
sidekick she is also totally ruthless in
a different way from the Joker just
remember the way she cut out the
Enchantress's heart in Suicide Squad
they're mad fighting skills are what
make the Joker and Harley Quinn such an
unstoppable team
unfortunately it seems like the Joker
tends to overshadow Harley as the main
fighter she isn't appreciated enough
cooler weapons on a similar note Harley
Quinn uses way cooler weapons than the
Joker the Joker originally used jokester
weapons like buzzers and razor cards
that was unique but it wasn't very
effective as his character developed we
saw him using more and more common
weapons but let's face it guns and
explosives are overdone then there's
Harvey Harley's iconic weapon is a giant
hammer its cartoonishly huge which makes
it extra awesome to see the tiny female
villain wielding it plus the hammer is
usually themed to match her outfit even
when she is taken down the good guys she
has a sense of style the hammer has
changed a lot throughout the years but
it's part of Harley's character she also
has pet hyenas that help her out in a
fight they're both adorable and
terrifying Harley Quinn doesn't get
nearly enough credit for her weapons but
she is resourceful and might lease a
very extra giant hammers and hyenas make
a bold statement of course the statement
it makes is that Harley's bonkers
awesome aesthetic when you picture the
Joker you probably come up with a pretty
standard image it doesn't matter which
version of the Joker you think of he
pretty much always has green hair a
purple suit and a creepy painted clown
face his aesthetic hasn't changed much
over the years but then there's Harley
Quinn unlike many beloved characters
that no one seems to mind when her
costume changes she started out looking
like a court jester
she wore red and black outfit and a
jester hat later we got to know her with
the pale blonde pigtails with pink and
blue tips her red and black outfit has
had many versions over the years it's
been a full body suit and a crop top
there have been short shorts and a
corset the latest live-action versions
have her wearing a red and white t-shirt
that says daddy's little monster she may
be a villain but she always has a sense
of style she doesn't need the same
Universal costume to be iconic the same
can't be said about the Joker
what he died for me loves fiercely we're
gonna be perfectly honest the Joker
doesn't deserve Harley Quinn here's the
thing about the Joker
he doesn't love anyone but himself if he
did he wouldn't treat his most loyal
companions so terribly many people have
suggested that he's sort of in love with
Batman but it's more of a creepy
obsession than love and the Suicide
Squad tried to make him out to love
Harley but the rest of DC cannon just
doesn't support that he thinks of her as
a possession or a minion on the other
hand Harley Quinn loves him fiercely she
puts her entire career and life on the
line to break him out of prison and she
shows repeatedly how much she loves him
she wants attention from him she listens
to him and comforts him when he's sad
she's the only person that has ever seen
him cry but he doesn't ever return those
basic signs of love Harley also loves
her friends deeply - she's no sociopath
she feels real love for the people in
her life independent woman Harley Quinn
does not get nearly enough credit for
her independence of course she doesn't
start out that way
Harley was essentially the Joker's
criminal prodigy but he treated her like
a minion he constantly bossed her around
and she did what he said for a while but
then Harley became her own person she
made friends with Catwoman and poison
ivy she's stopped putting up with all
the Joker's mean antics toward her
eventually she became a criminal in her
own right and she was really good at it
she got a solo series of really popular
comics and she's going to be in the new
birds of prey movie she doesn't need to
star alongside Joker anymore Harley
Quinn becomes the leader of an awesome
group of antihero women who save a young
girl the fact that she has gained so
much independence from the Joker is a
big deal honestly we never expected it
there's a lot more to Harley Quinn than
we ever knew do not say this oath
topless Lee
full of joy The Joker might release a
constant demented laugh he might play
jokes and have a carefree attitude about
his criminal activities but he's not
actually happy he's a pretty troubled
soul who is solely motivated by hatred
and a desire for violence Harley Quinn
is a completely different story
she is troubled too but she has a
distinct joy in her life
in fact the writers of DC say that
giddiness is what makes Harley Quinn who
she is
anyone that can pull off her girlish
excitement can do the character of
justice
she loves fighting and committing crimes
she doesn't just laugh because she's a
criminal
she laughs because she's enjoying
herself she's a wild and carefree soul
her insanity does not derive from the
fact that she's a monster is that she
has an off-the-wall loopy sense of humor
you can see it in her pet names for the
Joker like when she calls him puddin
it's in her choice of clothes and in her
big wild eyes and it's always in her
laughs more relationships the Joker
doesn't respect Harley Quinn but he is
weirdly codependent on her it's part of
what makes their relationship so
unhealthy in certain versions the Joker
has confided in her even as he treats
her terribly she's even tried to end her
life on more than one occasion Harley
has an unhealthy love for the Joker it
may be her defining relationship but
it's far from her only important
relationship
Harley forms a close-knit relationship
with poison ivy their friendship is deep
and real poison ivy is an important part
of helping Harley Quinn gain her
independence
eventually poison ivy and Harley became
more than friends for a little while at
least
Harley also befriends Catwoman who helps
her see that the Joker isn't always the
best boyfriend she has also had a
relationship with Deadshot although it
got creepy very quickly in some series
she even becomes friends with Batman and
seems to care about him her
relationships are more interesting than
the Joker's he is never really seen
having a relationship with anyone else
it just goes back to how much love
Harley has for the people in her life
character growth if there's one thing we
can count on from the Joker
it's that he'll always be the same he's
always mad and he's always obsessed with
Batman but he never changes in any
version of the DC Universe character
growth is what makes characters
interesting and Harley has so much
character growth it's hard to keep up
with she grows from a rigid lonely
psyche
hydrous to a carefree criminal she
starts out being bossed around
but then learns to stand up for herself
she gains her independence and makes her
own decisions and then she almost
becomes a hero in the live-action movies
we can't wait to see her to roasts and
birds of prey certain things about her
don't change like her feelings for the
Joker and her girlish excitement but
that's what makes her who she is
Harley has changed a lot and grown into
an even more exciting character it's
part of her appeal and it puts her on
the same level as the Joker
not all bad the Joker is purely evil he
exists solely to cause torment in Gotham
City and beyond she has never shown a
good side other than rescuing Harley and
Suicide Squad but even that was for
selfish reasons Harley on the other hand
does have a good side in the animated
series she ends up working for Batman
you can't be completely evil and work
for Batman she even comes to respect him
and they become friends Harley makes
conscious decisions to commit crimes but
even she has a moral code she won't
cross she won't hurt the people she
cares about like poison ivy she has a
sense of justice even if it is warped
but the Joker doesn't have any of these
tricks Harley has also been shown to
have regret for some of her actions
that's another thing we would never see
from the Joker
she's been flat out kind before and we
expect to see more of that in birds of
prey for more videos about the hottest
Hollywood characters be sure to
subscribe to the things don't want to
miss another video well you can get
notified about every new upload when you
subscribe to the things and click the
notifications bell check your
notification settings if you're watching
on your phone that's a wrap
witch villain do you like better Harley
Quinn or the Joker tell us in the
comments thanks for watching
show your love for Harley Quinn by
hitting the thumbs up button see you
next time
you